en 1942 sous la france occupée la jeune
versaillaise jacqueline fleury âgé de 20
ans entre en résistance avec sa famille
elle distribuer tracts journaux
clandestins participent à des réseaux de
renseignement et prend chaque jour de
plus en plus de risques
quand je rentrais de paris avec mon
petit chargement de journaux plans
dessins on pouvait être arrêté dans le
métro dans les rues dans les gares dont
les gars surtout il y avait la police
française la police allemande pour nous
la gestapo arrêté justement jacqueline
fleury letang février 1944 dans son
appartement versaillais elle est alors
envoyé avec sa famille à la prison de
fresnes puis déporté en allemagne
s'ensuivent sept jours de transfert
confiné dans un wagon direction le camp
de concentration de ravensbrück
nous recevions un numéro puisque à
partir de cet instant nous n'étions plus
des êtres humains
nous étions d'échec c'est à dire des
morceaux là c'est la négation de
l'humain c'est d'indication de lettres
en l'espace d'un an jacqueline changera
trois fois de camp et travaillera pour
l'armurerie allemande en tant que
prisonnière en 1945 elle s'évade avec sa
mère et deux autres détenus
elles seront rapatriés en france par
l'armée rouge
comme on avait toujours vécu par terre
moi je trouvais les bords des trottoirs
extraordinaire ça m'attirait pour
m'asseoir les gens quand j'entendrai
toujours ma mère me dire mais tu ne peux
pas faire sans nous sommes à versailles
un témoignage douloureux que cette
résistante retrace depuis plus de 70 ans
aux enfants dans les collèges et lycées
un devoir de mémoire que jacqueline
continue de perpétuer pour transmettre
son héritage culturel aux nouvelles
générations au fond quand on a peut-être
très dans un camp c'est aussi quelque
chose que je dis aux enfants que je
rencontre d'un professeur évidemment on
ne sort jamais complètement dingue quand
il n'y a pas un jour où on ne retrouve
pas quelque chose comptait les jours
depuis sept ans depuis de plus tard
5 combien ça fait jour sans compter tout
ce qu'on a laissé toutes nos compagnes
tous styles et tous tous que oui on a
encore dans caire